i love you and um tell your papa
that i love them too dwayne the rock
johnson just gave his three-year-old
daughter tia
the ultimate birthday surprise i mean
literally it all started on sunday when
dwayne posted this photo for his
daughter tia's third birthday
calling out what a loving kind tenacious
and tough little girl she is
he also added now that tia is old enough
to realize that her dad is maui from
moana
she has another very important movie
related question
quote daddy do you know aquaman
look i think anything's possible right
well it turns out the rock knew just who
to call
making tia's birthday wish come true by
surprising her with the video from
aquaman himself
jason mamoa i know you look to me and we
can hang out in the ocean there and i
will have a prison for you and jazzy
and all of our opponents can get
together and play
and maybe rock climb and go surfing
[Applause]
the actor reposted the adorable reaction
video on his
instagram and explained in the caption
when uncle maui calls you up and asks
for a favor
all my love to baby jazzy and baby tia
happy birthday beautiful
as for dwayne it seems like he's still
trying to wrap his head around the fact
that tia thinks aquaman is cooler than
his character in the dc universe
black adam
[Music]
i saw what aquaman just did is aquaman
cool
is he the coolest
who's cooler daddy
aquaman
[Laughter]
and while the verdict is still out on if
dwayne's daughter thinks he's cool
he definitely has the support of many
americans who'd like to see him run for
office one day
a topic he recently discussed on sunday
today with willie geist
i do have that goal to unite our country
and i also feel that
if this is what the people want
then i will do that a united country as
we know is is
is its strongest and i want to see that
for our country this dream has seemingly
been a long-term goal for the actor
in 2017 he told et he was humbled by the
public's positive response
but were you surprised how people ran
with it and said i like that idea i got
to tell you something kevin it was
it was really the it was incredibly
flattering i can tell you
i feel that what people are responding
to
i think with me is that i have a
i do a pretty good job uh in terms of
leadership and in terms of galvanizing a
lot of people and bringing them together
to get a job done and to be better but
that's what a president does
that is it's one of the qualities yes of
a president